on soit blanche maison merci d'être avec
nous on revient un petit peu dans le
passé pourquoi les etats-unis se
tire-t-il de ce traité ciel ouvert ben
comme vous l'avez dit dans votre sujet
au mois de mai donald trump part accusé
la russie de ne pas respecter l'esprit
du traité est en entière des gens le
survol de certaines zones
en effet à kaliningrad et aussi près de
la frontière de la quasi et l'ossétie du
sud mais en fait cette sortie six mois
plus tard c'est ce qui était prévu dans
le traité montre bien que donald trump a
une certaine allergie à tout dispositif
plus qui latéral il considère qu'il est
plus commode de jouer le rapport de
force bilatérale pour favoriser les
intérêts des états unis
et puis c'est l'un des épisodes nombreux
du retrait des états unis des traités
signés notamment avec la russie
parfois avec l'union soviétique qui
étaient des traités de contrôle des
armements donc des traités de
désarmement est en effet les états unis
ne supporte pas d'être contraint avec un
budget militaire qui est douze fois
celui de la russie ils considèrent
qu'ils ont plutôt intérêt à ne pas être
liés par des traités de ce genre et puis
enfin dernier élément tous les pays les
états unis la russie mais aussi la
france et beaucoup d'autres possèdent
des des satellites militaires qui ont un
degré de précision qui permet de saisir
au sol des deux des éléments très très
très petit inférieur à 1 mètre et par
conséquent finalement est-ce que ce
traité sur le ciel ouvert n'a pas
finalement une valeur est
essentiellement symbolique
serait-il toujours adaptés au monde qui
nous entoure
oui alors évidemment on a bien vu que
la russie mais aussi la pente
l'allemagne et la plupart des pays
signataires regrettent le départ des
etats-unis et considère que le traité
doit continuer de s'appliquer
et en plus on prévoir un probable retour
de joe biden lorsqu'il sera à la maison
blanche
donc si tous ces pays s'intéressent à ce
traité c'est qu'il y attachent un prix
ça veut donc dire qu'il a un sens mais
il s'est un traité encore une fois qui a
été conçu à l'époque de la guerre froide
même s'il n'a été signé qu'après la fin
de la guerre froide en 92 et s'il a été
mis en vigueur que dix ans plus tard
en réalité on voit bien qu'il s'agit
d'une mesure de confiance en autorisant
les pays de l'autre camp à faire des
survols de zone
mais naturellement après que l'agrément
été donnée sur le plan de vol des zones
survolées ce que kevin est évidemment
l'intérêt de la chose puisque les pays
survolés et est averti et doit être
d'accord alors on peut regretter aussi
que ce traité n'est pas évolué pour
couvrir aussi les conflits régionaux et
pour couvrir des défis plus récents
comme le réchauffement climatique ou
comme les enjeux environnementaux
ce trait retrait américain porte il un
coup à l'architecturé de sécurité
européenne oui d'une certaine manière
parce que c'est l'indication qu'une une
partie de l'establishment sécuritaire
américain remet en cause tous est traité
sur le désarmement qui ont été
construits qui ont été construits
longuement depuis l'époque de l'union
soviétique alors d'une m'ont dit que la
future administration américaine
reviendra probablement à cette école du
hameau nce control mais il n'est pas sûr
qu'elle y revienne complètement et elle
devra tenir compte aussi des nouvelles
réalités
l'une de ces nouvelles réalités comme
disait john bolton le conseiller pour la
sécurité de trump lutte de ces réalités
c'est l'émergence de la chine dans le
domaine militaire et la chine a
maintenant des moyens balistique
d'atteindre
tous les pays d'europe et d'atteindre
peut-être même probablement les états
unis par conséquent il va falloir mener
une réflexion de ce type et puis en
europe bien sûr l'architecturé de
sécurité européenne devra aussi être
remise sur la table le président de la
république française a lancé au fort de
brégançon cette idée d'une réflexion et
la réflexion est engagée sur le plan
franco russe d'une structure d'une du
futur de l'architecturé de confiance et
de sécurité en europe et par conséquent
ce retrait américain met le projecteur
sur cette reconstruction d'une
architecture de sécurité de confiance en
europe
merci claude hop danse maison expert en
relations internationales